hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer a question from one
of my newsletter readers Florence who is
having problems attracting good people
to her team and one of my advice so she
wrote in saying she's an entrepreneur
who's in the fashion designing I've just
started it's really tough for me to find
people who are interested in working
with me have the same vision and who
don't just want the the payor their
salary can you help what do i do so
Florence thank you the question very
common problem for a lot of
entrepreneurs if you look at most of the
entrepreneurs who have grown beyond
themselves and have a team almost always
the number one challenges is working
with their team and finding the right
people to come and join them so you're
not alone a lot of people going through
it here's some advice to try to help you
kind of get over that hump the first
thing I found so it sounds like for you
it's really an employee selection
problem so you have to get the right
people who believe in your vision who
want to come on not just for the money
but because they love what you're doing
so first step is for you to really have
a clear vision of what your company is
about so you're in fashion great what is
special about your business and fashion
that you're trying to accomplish so you
have to have a unique goal unique vision
to your business that nobody else has
that gets you personally excited because
when you're excited to follow a goal or
a vision you know that will that will go
to your employees as well and they'll
feed off your energy so you know maybe
you've defined that already and maybe
you haven't you haven't you want to
definitely do that exercise for yourself
because it's a great you know way to get
yourself excited about the business and
help clarify some of what you want to do
with your company once you have to find
that vision then you need to get people
on board who also believe in that same
vision so whenever you're doing your
your interviews and you're hiring you
want to make sure that they also have
that same passion of not just you know
wanting to make money everybody wants to
make money you know it's part of
survival but they want to work for your
company because they really you know
strongly believe
in your vision in my case for example I
love helping entrepreneurs and so that's
what our business is all about we love
helping entrepreneurs we try our best to
help entrepreneurs in as many ways as we
can through YouTube videos and
newsletters and content I just love you
know being able to see an entrepreneur
have a have a problem and you can help
them fix it and solve it that's what
gets me all excited and I try to bring
our people who are also excited by that
so you're coming to work for me not just
to be a marketing manager or content
writer or whatever position it is you're
coming on board because you also love
helping entrepreneurs you love
entrepreneurship even if you're not
entrepreneur yourself you just love the
world of entrepreneurs I also try to
hire people who are nice so one of the
things we look for is people who are you
got to be a nice person I think I'm a
pretty nice person and I like I found by
working with people who are not nice
that I like working with people who are
nice and i think my customers like
working with people who are nice so we
try to find people who are nice and we
put that in our job description and a
lot of people will look at that and say
they want people who are nice that
sounds so hokey pokey so Mickey Mouse
but that's fine because the people who
think that way are not going to be the
type of people who I want where the
people who see we help entrepreneurs and
we want nice people if they are you know
they love helping entrepreneurs and they
are nice they're going to say wow this
is really exciting this is a type of
place I want to be and that's what you
want to have you know clearly laid out
so the first step is for you to really
understand what your vision is about and
the type of people who you want to have
on board beyond the skill set right they
have to have certain skills but what
else are you looking for and the more
clearly you know that yourself it's
easier to explain that to people and get
them to self-identify say yes I'm that
type of person and they'll have a lot
more passion coming to your business and
hopefully you can build a team that will
be with you for a very long time so
hopefully that helps if you guys like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it what it's what makes me want to
make more these videos for you guys and
if you have a question or if you have a
comment please leave it below in the
comment section and thank you and
see you on the next episode
you